you learn about your friends in a couple
ways women and money number one like I
don't even want a friend that's not
abundant in both of those why well think
about it you got two guys
been friends 20 years one of them gets
married he goes over to the house all
the time hangs out the wife and the
husband start having a rocky ship of it
they get divorced the first person she's
gonna try to focus on and if he has not
done his work as a man to be in
abundance enough abundance to tell a
woman no as you just saw me do then he's
gonna sleep with him and then he ruined
a 20-year relationship with the only
friend he probably has over 30 minutes